some of you may have heard I just got
back from Armenia I was there no kind of
jet-lagged I was there last week the
reason I went is four years my assistant
Sona move seccion mm-hmm has been
talking about her Armenian culture and
how she's always wanted to go back to
her homeland of Armenia and so finally
you know in the wake of us going to Cuba
and people really enjoying that I
thought you know what I'm gonna take
Sona to Armenia I want to take her there
I will learn about the culture she will
be my ambassador to Armenia we'll have a
lot of fun and so we went and tonight I
can officially announce our show from
Armenia will air Tuesday night November
17 a really fun show November 17th and
you know it was really great we were
there for four full days it takes a
whole day to travel there I 24 hours to
get there and 24 hours to get back but
we were there for four days we went all
over the country we had some amazing
adventures here's just a tiny tiny tiny
little morsel
[Music]
but as InfoSec many countries this is
considered a threat you find one of
these on your doorstep yes I'm growing a
beard
I'm bi voices lower what is this oh it's
a helmet worn during a war I'm guessing
he didn't survive
no one should worry the crowd is
protected by a very thin piece of rope
[Music]
I'm still high and so this is such a
crazy trip I'm having there are no drugs
in this at all I'm seeing Chong and
Cheech there with President Garfield
during a minivan
[Music]
same country yeah and also I know every
other late-night host is going dammit he
beat us if he doesn't work
he'd beat us to her we could just bought
her tickets to Armenia but Conan beat us
again us to Armenia hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please